et les cherry pour commencer j'ai reçu
j'ai reçu l'amour en héritage mais pas
que ça j'ai reçu le test de culture
générale des miss france
un test de culture générale et miss
france et synthèse de 40 questions
allant de la politique au cinéma par
passe en passant par l'histoire ou les
réseaux sociaux
et je vais vous dire on va alors je vous
pouvez vous poser des questions regarder
or si vous savez chez vous en quelle
année a eu lieu la toute première
représentation de la cinéscénie du
puy-du-fou 68 78 ans de 1967 a dit vous
auriez peut être miss bah oui je pose
c'est bon vous delphine wespiser gains
histoire de france quel souverain était
surnommé l'empereur à la barbe bleue à
la barbe fleurie faut qu'on soit premier
ou charlemagne charlemagne charlemagne
non mais non souffle et charlemagne en a
passé mais c'est pas il est pas évident
à cet instant je sais mes proches de moi
que je voulais être miss france y à
s'imposer ces trois mousquetaires de
dumas dumas bien entendu alexandre dumas
et non pas victor hugo qui était proposé
également quelle ville s'appelait
autrefois lutte est mort alors et de
voir chez moi je suis pas venu à tpm
paix pour faire mes devoirs et ses parts
il s'est départi à lutèce et ouais
guillaume genton en mathématiques
comment appelle-t-on la demie droite qui
partagent un angle en deux angles ego
puisse dire a dit s'écrit la médiatrice
et non c'est la vie c'est le triste
alors vous faites très intelligent
ce coffret est arrivé être miss france
est con comme une aubergine mais si je
vous le dis chaque fois on n'est pas
chez votre maman ici quel architecte a
conçu construit la galerie des glaces au
château de versailles
ah merde jules hardouin mansart ou louis
le vau mansa mansart mansart bien sûr
bonne réponse est oui et en plus vous
étiez elle était là elle était sur les
travaux et sur les trappes
pour bernard pottier
l'an 2011 quel territoire est devenu le
101ème département français
la guyane où mayotte mayotte à vos
idéaux hasard mais la tâche
ces licences de sa vie je sais du soleil
et du soleil en france quelle
institution regroupe le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale le parlement où le
congrès parlement babeau elle est forte
celle ci quel personnage de roman chante
je suis tombé par terre c'est la faute à
voltaire st-gelais en plus chaque
gavroche gavroche il est pas si cons
enfin dernière question on avait regardé
voilà donc y'a plein de questions comme
ça voilà par exemple qu'elle chérit
française connaît un vrai succès à
l'étranger sous le nom de col maillage
annecy pour sortir et c'est donc voilà
le questionnaire miss france que vous
avez pas si j'arrive à rester herbe
tu avais réussi vous aviez réussi le
questionner au palais oui je pense que
j'ai réussi mais je ne m'en souviens
plus de la note parce qu'en fait quand
on a en dessous de la moyenne je crois
qu'on est déjà plus ou moins éliminés il
faudra voir la moyenne louis sinon ça
comme si on les voit l'art et moyennes
la moyenne de saint pascal brethes non
les 12 pour être dans les 12 finalistes
il faut ou avoir un test de culture
générale correct à la sortie la moyenne
d'être sérieux la savait pas mais oui je
sais pas qui va se passer là bas non
pour obliger oui si vous êtes comme un
art qui changent pas vous donner les
charges et la 205 m
on ne le croyez qu'un peugeot 306
j'allais pas si vous êtes comme en
sicile